but first he is the longest-serving
independent the United States Senate who
is running for president as a Democrat
Bernie Sanders
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good to see you smile you know you're
always so serious which is great because
we want a serious guy but you deserve a
smile you're a rock star now you know
and you know you got into this everybody
said it was just a boutique campaign
you're in New Hampshire you're within
ten points of Hillary you're drawing
such big crowds they have to change the
venues you've already got Hillary
Clinton talking like Elizabeth Warren
I'm guessing you're gonna say it's
because you have the right message yeah
look what the campaign is about it's a
very radical idea we're gonna tell the
truth
and the truth is that for 40 years the
middle class of this country has been
disappearing and there has been a huge
transfer of trillions of dollars in
wealth from working families to the top
1/10 of 1% and what the people of this
country are saying enough is enough our
government our country belong to all of
us and not just a few billionaire's so
let's dig down a little deeper into the
campaign I mean you are closing the gap
on Hillary but obviously she's still way
ahead with women you do very well with
men and the older older men especially
now some women you will just never get I
don't mean you personally but because
yeah obviously there's a lot of
enthusiasm for the first woman candidate
but you know I think where you could do
really well is with younger voters they
like Ron Paul
when he had that same sort of
authenticity thing going is your
campaign savvy about how to reach the
younger people because are you on tinder
well I will tell you that we have a very
active social media effort good in the
Senate we have more people on our
Facebook page than any other member of
the United States Senate were being very
and by the way that's sanders.senate.gov
and we are being very aggressive in
reaching out to young people look I
think what we want to do is tap build
the the idealism of the kids and what
the kids are saying for example is that
this country should lead the world in
transforming our energy system and
dealing with climate change and that's
it is she we're gonna talk about a whole
lot and you are right about what the
Pope did I mean this Pope is dare I say
been a miracle for Humanity he makes me
very conservative and economic issues
and that he spoke out on climate change
in his forceful a manner as he did is
just extraordinary one of the
embarrassments but atheists and Jews who
love the Pope
[Applause]
I mean one of the embarrassments that
goes on in this country today is we have
a major political party called the
Republican Party that is rejecting what
the overwhelming majority of scientists
are saying and that is of course climate
change is real and caused by human
activity and I think and I think the
fact that the Pope has spoken out will
head back to have a profound in yes all
of this world eat I mean he's got
religion science and economic morality
on his rise yeah
you